pain and gain this is one hell of an
interesting movie I really enjoy the
hell out of this [ __ ] flake Dwayne
Johnson is probably the best thing in
this movie this guy constantly gets
better per phone he's funny he's
charming he's sincere he brings a
surprising amount of emotional depth
just rock solid get it Dylan oh he's
black or not Mark Wahlberg is solid as
ever the guy is always great well not
always but he does your job in this
movie keep and use to make a very
unlikable person rather understandable
and everything too I didn't notice he
flares his nose a lot look at this
picture flare empty Maggie you're
probably asking yourself who the [ __ ] is
this guy well he does a good job in the
film and he doesn't play just a black
guy he actually does a very very good
job and provides really good support for
the film now let's talk about the thing
that everyone's talking about Michael
[ __ ] Bay how was his direction
surprisingly very good he brings that
Michael made touch of kinetic energy but
manages to make a movie that's actually
about people I actually think he was the
perfect director for this film is this
film has a lot of themes such as that
lust for the American dream you know
cars tits and sit gains and most
importantly cheating your way to there
and who else better to provide that type
of theme and energy then Michael Bay why
cuz you're going to be sort of an
egotistical maniac he managed to tell a
true story but in the most interesting
way by turning it into a dark comedy and
it manages to work somehow somebody dug
the hell out of this flick one of the
main reasons is because it really
challenges the audience's on whether or
not you should like these people and
when a film succeeds in causing such a
big debate about it I consider that a
success in its own right don't get me
wrong there's still some of those
Michael Bay touches like some hot
[ __ ] every now
put overall it's really about the people
plus this film really made me want to
work out when did that feeling go away
once a credit started rolling let me get
straight to the point here oh no I gotta
say pain and gain got it right alright
guys thanks for checking out my show why
don't you go ahead and scroll that
comment box below and tell me your
thoughts on pain and game or if you
haven't see you tell us why the [ __ ]
down CD and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of pain and gain go
ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see that I do with my buddy
Jerry and we have a special guest start
Aaron on the show and last not least if
you want to get updated every time a new
review of mine is Ella go ahead and
subscribe to my channel on the link
right there